now you may have seen this thumbnail on
youtube
i mean i can actually basically
guarantee that youtube has been shoving
this in your face
like click click click click it again so
you might be wondering
why why did this video in particular
go viral well that is what i'm going to
set out to explain
in this video but i'm going to start
with something that seems
unrelated which is youtuber
burnout now there's no secret there have
been a lot of youtubers recently talking
about burnout
people like casey neistat superwoman
ryan higa
grace helbig and many many many more
and i think when you have all of these
people with different youtube channels
different experiences
they're all saying something similar i
think it's worth
understanding that there may be sort of
a common factor at play amongst
all of them so what i'm actually going
to present is a kind of theory
of everything when it comes to youtube
everything from
youtuber burnout through to videos going
viral why do videos go viral on the
platform
right now okay so you know i think as a
viewer your response to burnout might be
to say
well these youtubers are just entitled
or they're soft or
you know boo hoo you have the best job
in the world or
your other response might be that
burnout happens in every industry
so why should we care about this
youtuber thing but i think that youtuber
burnout is a more specific phenomenon i
think there's something
particular going on here and it all
starts
with the youtuber life cycle i mean if
you think about a youtuber who's
complaining about burnout
you know they've had some success on the
platform where their views are rising
and of course that's exhilarating it
feels great and
you're working pretty hard but you're
seeing it pay off
and then at some point your views start
to falter
so maybe you work a little bit harder
but things don't really change
and and the views you know continue to
fall
i think there's a certain thing to do
with the psychology of anchoring
here you know once you have a certain
number of subscribers
then you know 100 000 views which might
be amazing in the beginning
feels like a horrible disappointment so
there's a real problem between
sort of expectations and reality and to
me
this is a big part of why youtuber
burnout happens
now if you look at what the youtubers
are saying about this
you find that a lot of them are taking
responsibility
themselves and they're also making some
clear cause and effect
relationships which you know
kind of seemed to make sense okay so
this idea we assume that
views reflect something about video
quality
we kind of make that assumption and so
when there are
you know fewer views taking place
that means the video is lower quality
this is just kind of
i think instinctive but i want to
question that
i also want to question these youtubers
who essentially put the blame on
themselves and say
you know they're just not making as good
videos anymore
to me i think there's something else at
play and it is the system
so from time to time i like to go over
to google trends where you can basically
search
any search term and see how much traffic
there is how many people are searching
that term at any given time
and if you search for veritasium
basically since 2004
you see well this kind of curve
which might make you ask the question
where on the youtuber life cycle
do you think i am and of course this
little spike here is from my black hole
videos
this over here uh must be some harry
potter fans who are bad at spelling
so this is how much people are searching
for me which i think kind of correlates
to
you know how much my videos are being
shown on youtube and how much people are
watching them and enjoying them
now let's look at a a similar channel
for comparison how about
the channel number file it's also an
educational channel but
it's uh you know very different made by
very different people and with very
different schedules very different
topics that we've tackled and yet these
graphs look pretty similar let me have a
look at one more
so this is the asap science curve
so here you have veritasium numberphile
and asap science
three educational youtube channels which
all follow
a fairly similar pattern on google
trends
so my question is you know why is this
why should we follow a similar trend
well the obvious answer is
the algorithm and the algorithm
has a very important job because in
traditional media
there are not that many works produced i
mean in american theaters last year
there were about
800 films 800 films that's it
on tv there were 500 scripted tv shows
but when it comes to youtube it doesn't
even compare
i mean i don't even think that they
advertise the number of hundreds of
hours
uploaded uh every minute the obvious
analogy is that you're really just
seeing the tip
of the iceberg but in the case of
icebergs you see
you know almost 10 percent of the ice
above the surface in the case of youtube
you're seeing just the tip of the tip of
the tip of the tip of the
tip of the iceberg basically
statistically speaking you were ignorant
of everything on youtube and yet
youtube claims that they have this
algorithm which you can think of like
the brain of the platform that can
connect an
audience that knows almost nothing of
what's on the platform
to the particular types of content they
like
and in the best case they would argue
youtube would argue that the
algorithm is basically the audience
you know the audience decides what they
want to watch and and
the algorithm is just reflecting that
but of course we are not
in this ideal world and the audience
itself
is always kind of shifting and
changing who they are and what they like
to watch and so
the algorithm you can think of as
following the audience the the algorithm
is is chasing this audience around and
trying to
reach them now what youtube doesn't much
consider
is that well the youtube creators use
their
content to try to uh chase
the algorithm so these youtubers who
would love to be creating content about
you know whatever they're most
passionate about in whatever way they
also
see what's popular on the site and they
try to make content that will
please the algorithm and so there's a
way in which the content is chasing the
algorithm the algorithm is chasing the
audience and if the content actually
manages to catch up with the algorithm
you get a kind of
perverse situation in which the
algorithm
is the content i mean what do i mean by
that
just a crazy thought experiment if
youtube wanted more videos of snails
they could make that happen they don't
actually have to go out and make any
snail videos if they just
you know promoted videos with snail in
the title tomorrow there's going to be a
whole bunch
on the front page and trending and then
creators be like oh snails are the new
thing and they're going to go make a
bunch of videos about snails
youtube would love to believe that that
creators don't care about the algorithm
but they do it's like the core aspect of
how creators decide what content to make
just as
a more down to earth example
i can show you a graph of the length of
my videos from
2011 through to today and what you see
is
at the beginning all of my videos
average about two or three minutes
in length but these days i'm fast
approaching an
average length of video of 10 minutes
now youtube never came to me and said
derek
you have to make longer videos all they
said was
well videos that are longer and get
longer watch time will be
promoted more on the site so people like
myself and
you know all the other creators who
wanted to be seen we made longer videos
it's just what we did now we know that
the algorithm is
always changing they're always trying to
optimize it make it work better
but they also change what it's trying to
optimize for
in the beginning it was simple just
views but they quickly figured out that
of course like a 20-minute view is worth
a lot more than a five second view
so the actual metric should be watch
time
and this uh was advantageous to people
like gamers because people like to watch
people play video games for
long periods of time they also reduce
the latency of the algorithm by which i
mean
it updates every 10 minutes instead of
say every day
and that's beneficial for news content
and things that are really time
sensitive and to me
as a youtuber what this means is it's
impossible to be
an expert on youtube if you look at
what it takes to become an expert at
anything according to the nobel prize
winning economist
daniel kahneman you need of course many
many hours of practice
effortful deliberate practice and on
youtube
i would argue we get that you also need
timely feedback and again on youtube
we're
given plenty of tools to be able to see
how our videos are performing
but when it comes to a reliable
environment
this is an environment in which the
rules of the game aren't changing so you
can think of something like
chess it's possible to be a chess expert
because
in the middle of a game of chess the
rules don't suddenly change on you
now on youtube that is not true we
are not playing by the same rules the
whole time because the algorithm
is constantly changing and so that puts
us in this position where
it's kind of impossible to be experts
and instead
we're a little bit more like caged
pigeons
okay go with me on this uh there was
this famous experiment where
you know pigeons were put in a cage with
a lever and uh if they pushed the lever
then they would get some food
and so they very quickly learned that
they needed to push the lever and the
food would come out
so that's fine but in another part of
the experiment
they disconnected the lever from the
food output
and they just supplied food into the
cage kind of
at random and what did the pigeons do
well they started to do the types of
behaviors that they were doing when the
food appeared so
if one was preening itself then it would
keep preening itself with the
expectation that food was coming and
this one maybe it was pecking the ground
so the point being they started
to engage in these superstitious
behaviors
um because they had related some sort of
cause and effect but there actually
wasn't a cause and effect there
and to me this partly explains the whole
youtube burnout phenomenon
because you have these creators who are
stretching themselves to try to chase
that algorithm
meanwhile the algorithm is constantly
shifting and so you never feel like an
expert and never quite know what's going
on even though you're constantly trying
to relate
cause and effect now i can understand
why the algorithm has to change i mean
in the early days of youtube
it was this situation where if you had
subscribers you were golden because
the next time you uploaded some content
then youtube would show it to all your
subscribers you'd get a ton of views
youtube would say oh this is a popular
video show it to even more people
getting you even more subscribers so the
next time you launch another
video then it goes to more subscribers
more views and it was just this
positive feedback loop where you would
grow and grow and grow a channel so the
rich got richer
and small channels stayed small so
obviously we needed something to break
the cycle
and so youtube started doing some
experiments
where they would essentially you know
change
what was recommended to your audience so
they would stop
showing some of the content from certain
subscribers
and they saw what happened to views so
they started
really disconnecting the subscribers
from the channel no longer was a
subscription like i want to see
every video by this person it was more
of like a suggestion that
maybe something this person creates is
something i might like to see
and what youtube found when they did
that was that the number of views on the
platform the amount of watch time
all rose dramatically so for youtube
to get growth of the site they found
that reducing the importance of
subscriptions
was essential and this kind of makes
sense if you think about it i mean
if you make one great video that doesn't
necessarily mean that every video you're
gonna make is gonna be great
so it makes sense for youtube to step in
and play some role
in terms of determining what gets shown
to which
audience members now as has been
observed by
matpat previously moving away from
subscriptions
moves youtube back to what it was like
to sell newspapers
on the street you really had to inspire
people to buy on the spot you have to
serve up really sensational
news items this is also called yellow
journalism
it was only once the newspapers built
subscription models
that you know newspapers could make
sober journalism
a reality something that they focused on
because they already had your eyeballs
they didn't have to fight for that sort
of attention
they didn't have to be as sensational
but youtube
is going in the opposite direction
reducing the importance of subscribers
means increasing the importance of
sensationalism
and clickbaity thumbnails and so
a few weeks ago i was out at the creator
summit in new york
and i met mr beast i showed him some of
the footage
from this video i was working on about
the shade balls in l.a reservoir
and mr beast took one look at it and he
said to me
that's a banger which i think is pretty
funny but i think
clearly he knew that this was going to
be a video that would take off
and uh we talked about titles and
thumbnails you might have noticed that
the thumbnail borrows a bit from say
his work with serial and orbeez in
backyards and i told him that i was
thinking about calling it something like
throwing shade balls and he was like
no he suggested why are there
96 million black balls on this lake now
i changed it to reservoir because i mean
let's be real that's what it is but it
just goes to show how important the
title
and thumbnail are what i learned talking
to mr beast
was that going viral you can boil down
to
two metrics you need to do two things
with your video
in order for it to go viral and i mean
tens of millions of views as his channel
shows
okay the first thing maybe not
surprising is watch time
so when people click on your video they
actually have to watch a significant
portion of it it's useful if that's sort
of seven or eight minutes now that is
the actual time that they watch
so you need a longer video than that say
15 minutes
if you want the average watch time to be
around that seven or eight minute mark
now for me
watch time is not that exciting of a
metric to know that i have to hit
because i know that most people already
watch most of my videos
so for me the big insight came with
number two if you want a viral video
you need to have a high click-through
rate so that is
the total number of clicks on your
titles and thumbnails
divided by the number of times that
title and thumbnail have been shown
that is your click-through rate and mr
beast showed me this graph
showing that as you approach you know 10
20
30 click-through rate then the number of
views and the number of impressions that
video will get
just skyrockets it jumps dramatically
now on the one hand that kind of makes
sense because you know people are
clicking a video obviously you're going
to get more views
but it is such a dramatic increase that
it really turns the site
into a place where the title and
thumbnail are
everything you can have a great video
but unless you have a great hook to get
people
in it's not going to go viral and so
it was amazing to hear all these
different youtubers talk about how they
optimize a thumbnail
many people told me that when they were
working on a thumbnail for a new video
they would actually photoshop it onto
a screenshot of their current youtube
home screen in various positions and
just
see how eye-catching it was they're
really working hard to make
these thumbnails as clickable as
possible it's like
weaponizing the thumbnail and that arms
race is only set to
increase with the introduction of
real-time click-through rate which is
coming out in
a month or two so what you can bet will
happen is that creators will launch a
video
and then they'll be sitting there with
all these different variants of
thumbnails
and they'll be swapping them out and
looking at what that does
to click-through rate and then going
with the one that leads to
the greatest click-through rate and you
can imagine if you don't do this
you're going to be left behind because
all the other creators
are are sitting there swapping their
thumbnails to get the
highest engagement that they possibly
can on their videos and if you're not
doing that
then your videos will end up getting
buried
so acknowledging that this is the
reality of youtube
i want to outline to you my plan for
what i will do going forward
first and foremost i want to keep making
high quality videos because if i don't
do that
i'm not going to be happy i won't be
satisfied and neither will you
but second of all i'm going to have to
choose
topics that are more clickable because
frankly if i'm going to work
for days and weeks and months on a video
i would like that video to get say 10
million views instead of
half a million so a lot of that comes
down to is this topic
clickable and so number three
i'm gonna have to use some click baity
titles and thumbnails
and uh i apologize for that but it just
seems like
it's an existential threat that if you
don't do that uh your channel will not
be around for very long and you'll be on
that sort of
downward slide i'd love to know what you
think if you think it's a good idea a
bad idea
uh i'm totally open to hearing you out i
mean casey neistat
talked about how he's gotta trust his
audience you know to come back to him
the truth is the audience only knows
you're there if they see your titles and
thumbnails
i went to buy something at b h a little
while ago and the guy was like oh hey
i love your videos and then he said are
you still making them
and i was like yeah yeah i'm making how
do you not know
and i also see comments on my videos
where people are like oh great here's a
veritasium video see you again in six
months
but i'm like no i'm making these every
week every other week
like i'm making them you just gotta know
that they're here but you can only know
that they're there if they surface to
the tip of the tip of the
tip of the iceberg which now is a
click-through rate game
[Applause]
on the one hand you could be a little
bit disappointed by the way
the game is working right now but on the
other hand i challenge you to think of a
better way
because they have this limited real
estate
in which to show people potential videos
they might be interested in
and of course they want to put the
videos there that people are most likely
to click
and then most likely to watch once
they've clicked it and
like part of me is like yeah i guess
that's kind of fair like would you make
the argument that you should put some
videos there
that people are less likely to click
no i mean that doesn't seem to make any
sense
so i kind of feel like this is the
inevitable
rational endpoint for any algorithm that
is trying to optimize
what people are watching we want to give
you the things
that you want to watch and you indicate
your desire
by clicking on them but by doing that it
also means that things that are just
less catchy less sensational
don't rise into this level here
and i wonder more broadly
how does that affect us how does that
affect the youtube platform
if the youtube platform becomes like a
real click bait site
who wants to go there what types of
audience will will come there will there
even be
an audience for educational content i
think it's all these
decisions about the system and the
algorithm that determine what
the actual media looks like what content
is created
what people come to the site what
audiences are served there
and i think this is a broader issue than
just youtube i mean
everywhere now we can be served the
things that
we really want but what does that world
look like
i mean you might have thought it would
be this utopia
but i would argue that it's not because
it
it silences all these voices that you
would otherwise get
you know in a more curated marketplace
if you're just going for the things that
drive the clicks
that is a very skewed view on the world
and i'm not sure
it's for the best but there is one way
on youtube at least to short-circuit
this effect and it is
[Applause]
to ring that bell and you're like
oh the whole point of this video is to
get to this point and tell you to ring
the bell
i mean no if you want to ring the bell
i encourage you to do that now because i
feel like i never encourage people to
subscribe or ring the bell
on this channel because it seems needy
and i think you can do whatever you want
whenever you want it
but in this ecosystem where
click-through rate is king
where millions of black balls on a
reservoir is the thing that is going to
rise to the surface
uh the only way to get around that is to
have people who are notified
every time i make something so i want
you to think about the videos
that i've made you know in the past and
so far this year and think about
do you want to know about every single
one of those
and if you do then i encourage you to
click the bell and the more people who
do that
the less i will be driven to make
clickbaity titles and thumbnails
and videos because i'll know that i can
reach my audience without having to
appeal to you know the basest instincts
of people so if you want to see more of
what i'm doing
click subscribe ring the bell and if you
don't then please
you know unsubscribe because it's good
to give youtube as clear of signals
as possible but i think there is a bit
of hope for the future because
what i've described is the way youtube
appears to be working right now
but i think that well we know that the
algorithm is always shifting
and what i've heard is that the
direction youtube wants to go
is optimizing for long-term satisfied
watch time that's got three pieces you
have to look at
are people coming back time after time
if they watch someone's videos do they
come back time after time for months
that would be one signal are they
watching for a long period of time
that's also a sign that people are
enjoying it and finally there's the
satisfied piece are people
satisfied by the things that they've
seen this is a new metric to add in
and how do you really gauge satisfaction
well youtube is experimenting with
surveys
surveys just like this one and
they will hopefully allow us to come to
a different place
where the algorithm isn't just about
click-through rate and watch time but
it's also about
satisfaction how much you're driven to
come back how much you really
love the content so my great hope is if
we move in this direction
there may be a time in the future where
click-through rate is no longer
king i'd love to know what you think so
let me know down in the comments
and i'm going to jump straight into end
screen here i'm going to post a few
thumbnails
for videos that are not particularly uh
clickbaity
um so feel free to click these i mean
you're gonna look at them and be like i
don't wanna click that but
that's exactly the point these are
apparently good videos uh that maybe
just aren't as catchy in terms of titles
and thumbnails
you wanna subscribe you can click up
here and
yeah thanks for listening to the rant
that i've given many times to
whoever will listen